ضخمه بؤره القتال الرئيسيه في اوكرانيا
التي تشهد اشد المعارك واشرسها منذ اشهر
بدات تسودها حاله من الهدوء نسبيا وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه افادت بان الهجوم
الروسي على باخمت توقف بشكل ملحوظ ومن
المحتمل ان يكون السبب وراء فشل الهجوم هو
نتيجه الاستنزاف الشديد والتوتر في
العلاقه بين الجيش الروسي وقوه
فاجنرالروسيا عزز ذلك رئيس اركان الجيش
الاوكراني قائلا ان المعركه في المدينه
بدات تهدا بفعل جهود القوات الاوكرانيه في
تصدي القوات الروسيه ورغم ان موسكو تتلهف
للانتصار في هذه المعركه لاعتبار ضخمه
نقطه تقدم على الخريطه العسكريه لروسيا
الا ان قواتها اصيبت بالارهاق بالقرب من
بخبط وتفقد الكثير من القوه وفق قائد قوات
المش الاوكرانيه
الرئيس الاوكراني فلو ديمير زيلينسكي
بدوره اعترف بان القوات بلاده لن تتمكن في
الوقت الحالي من شن هجوم مضاد دون تجويدها
بدبابات ومدفعيه وانظمتها
اليابانيه مطالبا حلفاء كييف بدعمها
بالمزيد من الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه مع
استمرار اعاده الاعمار في مدن وقرى
اوكرانيه التي عانت من هجمات روسيه بشكل
كبير وفق الرئيس الاوكراني رشا خياط
العربيه